and we have another game with the white
pieces let's play e4
now most people at this level of course
do play e5
this guy plays the alakan now the alakan
it's a hyper modern opening i know it's
become a meme at this point for me to
talk about that
and the drawback of the alkyne is that
it doesn't push any pawns
and when you push it when you get your
pieces out first those pieces become at
a very
fundamental level susceptible to attacks
by the puns
and that is why white's best and most
topical move in this position
is considered e4 to e5
[Music]
which on on its face is a pretty pretty
risky move if you think about it just
like pushing your pawn up it's not
something you should do lightly
the issue is black doesn't have any of
his fonts out and so this knight
okay so knight g4 is not yeah mango ingp
the real prophet okay he resigns
instantly that blunders the knight
um yeah that blunders the knight
and and and one thing that i often see
by the way to make a quick lesson out of
this knight d5 of course being
the move here um there's two things i
have to say on a serious note yeah let's
analyze it
the first is when you have a committal
pawn move like that you have to
understand what squares have been left
behind
so what squares are now accessible to
your pieces that were previously in
accessible that can help you
update your board state so to speak and
not miss moves like knight d5 right
which were previously impossible because
you had a pawn on e4
by the way like knight c3 is also
possible move this transposes into
vienna
but this would transpose into a
favorable version of the scandinavian so
d5 actually is
a very solid move as well now i'm
playing black once again i'm going to
play very positionally with black
that's the concept behind the speeder at
least at the start as we rise through
the beginner ranks
so e3 the van cruz i mean e3 is not a
terrible move
i'll talk a little bit about the general
mentality you should have with offbeat
openings i mean e5
this is sort of a reverse french i mean
there's nothing wrong inherently about
playing a reversed french thank you
risky play
but bishop c4 is is not good so he's not
developing
his knight before his bishop he's not
doing a great job
of occupying the center and uh
he's giving us a chance to occupy the
center with tempo
via the move d5 attacking the bishop
right he might give us a check on b5
um but that's clearly not scared bishop
b3
okay so i think that some players get
the temptation here
to play c5 and to continue occupying the
center with pawns but
as i've made very clear in the first
speed run
controlling the center is a is a balance
between
controlling with pawns obviously on the
one hand but on the other hand not
overdoing it and not forgetting to
develop your pieces because
you know and again this has become a
meme at this point but there are
openings designed
to overextend you in the sense that you
control the center with too many pawns
and those pawns start to crumble
so instead of playing c5 let's focus on
piece development let's go knight f6
supporting the pawn where should this f8
bishop go
what would be well okay not immediately
he's got knight c3
so one possibility is just to go knight
c6
yes so the ideal square for the bishop
is definitely d6
several reasons it supports e5 and in
the event that white castle's short
which is very likely
you can envision a scenario where we
play the move e5 before and this
you know this sets up potential greek
gift sacrifice ideas
or attacking ideas now um
can we play bishop d6 immediately and
if not why not and what can you propose
to fix the problem before you play
bishop d6
so it's not knight b5 that's the problem
and i'll explain why afterwards but
you're close it's knight takes d5 right
knight takes d5 wins the pawn
so a great move in this position is c7
to c6
defending the pawn with another pawn
building up a pawn chain always a good
thing
and paving the way for bishop d6 now i
know what some of you guys are thinking
like doesn't this take away
the c6 square for that where are we
gonna put this knight and i think the
way that some players are taught
um is slightly um you know
it's reasonable when you're first
learning to always want to put your
knights on c6 and f6
but you can you can put your knight on
d7 that's it's not the end of the world
um in most cases and you shouldn't think
of it as a huge concession or anything
of that sort c6 and f6
are the conventional squares they're
usually going to be the best squares
but chess is a game of trade-offs
sometimes you have to do something in a
slightly inferior manner
and that doesn't mean your position is
bad so here we play bishop v6
as we had intended right supporting the
pawn
yeah so i'll explain after the game the
zen behind why we didn't play bishop e6
that would not have been a bad move by
the way but i think c6 is better
and there is a a principle that stands
behind that knight g5
sort of a typical a typical move
um but it doesn't actually do anything
right it just sort of
now the reason knight five is usually
played is to attack f7 but here we're
not
white is not attacking f7 so
h6 is a very
uh sensible reaction to this but what i
would advocate what i would do here in
the name of playing more solidly is
actually just
to ignore this what i want to show you
guys is if we just castle
this single night even though it looks
scary and i remember hafu
robert hess my partner in crime he was
telling me
hafu had this you know issue at first um
where she was afraid of moves like
knight g5 and
there was a an aha moment when she
realized that
uh that peace doesn't
do anything just just because it's it's
on your side of the board it actually
could be an
asset for you and this is where it
becomes an asset for us
um what should we do now he's got an e4
he's trying to control more of the
center
but he's not ready for it his pieces are
all over the place and now he can play
h6 attack the knight if the knight moves
then this e4 pawn is attacked twice and
only defended once
once the knight was he can try a fishing
pole idea with h4 i don't think it's
going to work though
and if he does that we'll deal with that
when it comes when when he plays it
right so by reserving
h6 for a more opportune moment we're
going to gain more
from playing it thank you bullseye 8080.
now you shouldn't take this too far
sometimes like a move like nitro5
really is scary um none of this
should be taken too generally but
because white hasn't really developed
his pieces particularly well and we have
a strong pawn center
there's no reason we should fear this
okay so
there's several things we could do we
could take on e4 that's the typical move
we could take the knight and ruin his
pawn structure
but that's a little bit double edged
because that also opens up the g
file and you guys should be able to see
right off the bat why
that could actually backfire in some
cases so if we were to play
in a very simple way let's just take the
pawn let's not
even bog ourselves down too much
um and and kill you know
unnecessary time trying to evaluate
whether bishop takes h3 is good
and the point that i want to make here
is oftentimes
if you're agonizing over a decision do i
take that piece do i trade
simply not doing it and finding an
alternative can be a
very good practical solution right in
most positions
you're going to have several good
alternatives
and if you see the bigger picture and
you can save yourself a lot of time and
a lot of
um negative sort of emotions
by cutting out this kind of vacillation
that often happens
all right uh yeah bishop g4 now that's
not the best move i just want to show
that even playing in this very simple
way can
can be very powerful or at least
powerful enough to be
pretty decent players um
okay so rook f1 now
he's maybe was trying to castle i don't
know
uh but in any case this leaves his king
stranded in the center
um and not only does it leave his king
stranded in the center
i'm also noticing that he hasn't touched
most of his queen side
which essentially means that his queen
is actually
really hemmed in and because it's hemmed
in what move comes to mind immediately
to exploit that i mean this is simple
bishop g4 attacking the queen
the queen has no squares he's gonna have
to either move the knight back and block
it oh
that's ugly or he's gonna have to play
f3 and if he plays
f3 we take it he takes back and then the
knight loses
the support of the g2 pawn okay so f3 we
take that pawn
and now he loses more stuff he can avoid
taking this punt then we're going to
take his pawn with the discover
i mean this is just completely crushing
and we didn't even really do
anything tactical here we just played
sensible developing moves
okay i think when you first start chess
as a kid
particularly as a young kid i know it's
it's very
cliched to advocate this trope but fun
is incredibly important it's more
important sometimes than
like maximizing immediate learning so
puzzles for example are going to be more
important at the start than
you have to finish this chess book um
and
you know you have to develop a
relationship where
they're not crushed by a loss that has
to happen early as well okay so now we
take the queen
and the game is over off the queen the
hero is going for the tier one
okay so he resigns we're over 700
and you know again um
on analog thing over the product so e3 i
think this is called the van
van cruise opening technically or it can
be thought of as a reverse french now if
you are playing a reverse french you can
play d4 you can even play e4 and then
you have e4 e5 with colors reversed
um the bishop c4 is um
and that's the sort of classic you know
that's a that's a beginner
a category of mistakes that you'll see
pretty often
which i would say there's like two dials
right you have the
control the center dial and then the
developer pieces dial and
when those are miscalibrated you can do
too much of one too little of the other
and that's what you see here like white
hasn't done enough controlling the
center
with puns and he's hastily getting the
pieces out and that can be
very ineffective the weight of the
pieces isn't felt
so that's why it's so important to play
one of these two moves and to
focus on controlling at least part of
the center with pawns
then you guarantee yourself and this
might have been a mouse slip
um so anyways e5 bishop c4 d5 now the
one
instructive moment here i think is in
this case some people are asking well
why don't i
essentially solve two problems at once
and get my bishop out
defend this pawn and prepare bishop d6
and
the rule that i that i you know sort of
talked a lot about
in the previous speed run is a
principle that essentially says when
there's anything that you want to do
right a task that you want to accomplish
on the board
generally speaking it's going to be the
better to accomplish it with the piece
of
of least value um okay so what does that
mean now in this case you want to
you want to support the pawn you can do
that with a bishop or you can do it with
a pawn upon us has less value see what
you want to use the plan and the
motivation behind the zen behind that is
simply that you want to leave
open uh you want to be as flexible as
possible you want your
heavy duty pieces to have the freedom
to do the important things on the board
and you don't want to burden them too
early
with stuff that you could be doing with
the pawn by the same token
you know you don't usually want to
relegate your rook to a defensive task
if you can perform the same task just as
well with the bishop thank you just call
me kyle
now that's a you know that should be
taken
with a major grain of salt because in
many cases
you know you have to consign a rook to a
defensive test because maybe the bishop
isn't as good at it
and bishop b6 is by no means is this a
mistake or a bad move
but c6 not only is this following the
principle but it's actually more robust
to defend this pawn with another pawn
this creates a pawn chain and so the
bishop is essentially taken out of
commission
i hope that makes sense so knight f3
bishop d6
knight g5 right we ignore castles e4 h6
attacking the knight
he drops the knight back with d takes e4
now the technically the best
sequence here would be to go bishop g4
attack the queen
force him to play f3 that weakens this
diagonal now we take the knight
now we look at this position what do we
want to accomplish well we want the
queen
to land yeah so there's definitely more
to talk about and
all of these concepts that i'm laying
out right now in general terms i'm going
to try to expand on
further when i get to a higher rating
that's the sort of progression right
we go into more detail whoa stephen gray
with five gifted
oh okay um
so we will uh delve into all these
concepts
in greater detail but now it's time for
me to pause i have to go i have some
sessions coming up
i will see you guys later thank you so
much everybody for the support for
keeping it wholesome i always appreciate
it
uh this community is awesome so hope you
guys enjoyed
your time have a good rest of the day
enjoy peter's lecture
and i'll see you guys later bye
[Music]
everybody